(ruissellement de la pluie)
(détonation)
- Wow!
- C'est à l'arbalète
que Florence tente d'abattre
son premier chevreuil.
FLORENCE RICHARD, 15 ans
- Au début, c'est stressant, là,
mais c'est... je sais pas, c'est
le fun. C'est comme l'adrénaline
puis tu veux l'avoir, là.
- Avec sa famille,
elle participe à la fin
de semaine de la relève
organisée par le ministère de la
Forêt, de la Faune et des Parcs.
Deux jours de chasse réservés
uniquement à la relève
accompagnée d'un mentor qui,
lui, n'a pas le droit
de chasser.
ÉRIC RICHARD, père de Florence
- C'est merveilleux.
Ça lui donne toute une chance.
On a le temps de s'occuper d'eux
autres comme il faut aussi.
- Une activité qui a débuté
en 2020 et qui gagne
en popularité.
DANIEL LABONTÉ, ministère des
Forêts, de la Faune et des Parcs
- Lors de la première édition,
je vous rappelle, 696, bien sûr,
participants en pleine pandémie.
1624, c'est un chiffre
quand même assez significatif.
On parle d'une hausse
extrêmement importante ici par
rapport à la première édition.
- Selon les chiffres
du ministère de la Faune,
le nombre de chasseurs est
en constante diminution
au Québec depuis 2013.
Cela est dû notamment au
vieillissement de la population,
mais également en raison
de l'écotourisme qui change
notre rapport à l'environnement
et à la diminution de
la consommation de viande,
encouragée par le mouvement
vegan. Il se tue en moyenne
50 000 chevreuils chaque année
au Québec sur un total
de 325 000 bêtes.
Pour contrôler les populations,
la chasse sportive fait partie
de la solution.
ALAIN BRANCHAUD, biologiste
Société, la nature et les parcs
- On a tellement détruit
les cycles naturels en
détruisant les habitats que
la chasse effectuée par l'humain
devient un mécanisme de contrôle
des populations là où il y a
de trop fortes densités,
qui est vraiment essentielle
pour maintenir en vie
les cheptels, mais aussi
pour éviter les dommages
à l'environnement.
- Près des deux tiers
des participants à la fin
de semaine de la relève
ont entre 12 et 17 ans.
Ils espèrent tous abattre
un animal d'ici dimanche.
Florence, elle, a réussi.
Elle a tué un mâle à 6 pointes
en fin de journée, tout comme
cet autre chasseur de 14 ans.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada,
Saint-Michel-des-Saints.